♪
>> Tucker: THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS SUING THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA OVER ITS
AGGRESSIVE STAND AGAINST
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION LAW.
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN OF
CALIFORNIA CALLS THIS AN ACT
OF WAR AND IT IS.
BUT WHO FIRED THE FIRST SHOT
IS THE QUESTION.
CALIFORNIA OFFICIALS ARE
TRYING TO UNDERMINE, AS WE
SAID, THE LAWS THAT CONGRESS
PASSED.
OAKLAND MAYBE LIBBY SCHAAF
PUBLICLY WARNED OF ICE RAID
SO CRIMINALS COULD GO INTO
HIDING AND ESCAPE AGENTS.
GABBY
GAVIY
GAVIN NEWSOM SAYS OTHERS
SHOULD IMITATE HER.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: WHEN YOU HAVE THE
LARGEST STATE IN THE COUNTRY
SAYING IT'S ILLEGAL FOR
ANYONE WHO LIVES IN THAT
STATE, PRIVATE CITIZENS TO
COOPERATE WITH YOU, A
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY, WHAT DOES THAT DO TO
THE WORK YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA?
>> IT MAKES OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT DUTIES A LOT
MORE DIFFICULT IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
RATHER THAN TAKING CUSTODY
OF A CRIMINAL ALIEN WHO IS A
PUBLIC SAFETY THREAT INSIDE
THE SECURITY AND SAFETY OF A
COUNTY JAIL.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> WHERE WE DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO WEAPONS.
NOW WE ARE FORCED TO GO INTO
NEIGHBORHOODS, PLACES OF
EMPLOYMENT TO LOCATE THESE
PUBLIC SAFETY THREATS.
ON THEIR TURF, WHERE THEY
COULD HAVE ACCESS TO WHO
KNOWS WHAT WEAPONS.
MY BIGGEST CONCERN IS ONE OF
MY AGENTS IS GOING TO KNOCK
ON THE DOOR SOME DAY AND HE
IS NOT GOING TO GO HOME THAT
NIGHT.
VERY UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE HE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
APPREHEND THAT PERSON IN A
JAIL AND NOT BE FORCED TO GO
ON HIS TURF TO ARREST HIM.
>> Tucker: THIS IS MAKING IT
MORE DANGEROUS FOR FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION AGENTS BUT THERE
IS IRONY HERE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CLAIMING YOU ARE
GOING TO DOOR AND ROUSTING
THE INNOCENT.
YOU ARE SAYING THEIR
POLICIES ARE MAKING YOU GO
DOOR TO DOOR.
>> SANCTUARY CITY POLICIES
ARE FORCING OUR HAND, RIGHT?
FOR DECADES WE HAVE ACCESS
TO COUNTY JAILS.
WE CAN TAKE, YOU KNOW,
SOMEONE IN THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY AND SITTING IN A
COUNTY JAIL.
WHICH MEANS THEY ARE NOT A
CHOIR BOY.
LOCALS AND STATE OFFICIALS
ARE MADE A DECISION TO LOCK
THESE PEOPLE UP.
FOR DECADES WE WENT TO THE
JAIL, IDENTIFIED THEM AS
ILLEGAL ALIENS AND TAKEN
THEM INTO CUSTODY AND
REMOVED THEM FROM THE
COUNTRY AND COMMUNITY.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A LIMITED
THEY DON'T SHARE INFORMATION
WITH US.
NOW WE ARE FORCED TO GO IN
NEIGHBORHOODS, WHICH WHEN
THE GOVERNMENT SAYS HE IS
PROTECTING IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES AND THE MAYOR
SAYS SHE IS PROTECTING
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES.
THEY ARE NOT.
THEY ARE RELEASING CRIMINAL
ALIENS BACK INTO THE VERY
COMMUNITIES THEY LIVE AND
VERY VICTIMIZE.
THEY ARE PUTTING IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES AT INCREASED
DANGER OF CRIME AND THEY PUT
THE IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY AT
INCREASED ARREST BY SIZE.
BECAUSE WHEN WE GO TO A
HOME.
IF WE FIND OTHERS THEY WILL
BE ARRESTED, TOO.
THEY HAVE ACTUALLY PUT THEM
IN A BAD POSITION.
I WILL ADD THIS.
IF THEY WENT TO THE
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY AND
ASKED THE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY WHAT WOULD YOU
RATHER HAVE ICE IN A COUNTY
JAIL OR IN YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD, I GUARANTEE
THEY WOULD TELL YOU THE
COUNTY JAIL.
>> Tucker: HOW DOES IT MAKE
YOU FEEL TO HEAR YOUR AGENTS
DESCRIBED IN EFFECT AS
BIGOTS, AS A DOMESTIC
GESTAPO BY DEMOCRATS IN
CALIFORNIA?
>> IT'S AN INSULT TO THE
20,000 AMERICAN PATRIOTS
THAT WORK FOR ICE.
THESE ARE MEN AND WOMEN THAT
GET UP EVERY DAY AND STRAP A
GUN TO THEIR HIP TO DEFEND
THIS NATION.
THEY LEAVE THE SAFETY AND
SECURITY OF THEIR HOME EVERY
DAY TO PROTECT THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS, TO PROTECT
THE COMMUNITY.
AND THEY ARE ENFORCING A LAW
THAT CONGRESS ENACTED.
THEY ARE DOING THEIR JOB,
THEIR SWORN OATH.
IT'S AN INSULT TO MANY FINE
MEN AND WOMEN.
>> Tucker: YOU DON'T MAKES
THE LAWS.
CONGRESS DOES.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND WHEN
BRIAN FALLON A FORMER
SPOKESMAN FOR HILLARY
CLINTON SAYS THE DEMOCRATS
OUGHT TO RUN ON ELIMINATING
ICE?
>> YOU KNOW WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE WORK ICE DID, HOW MANY
CRIMINAL ALIENS HAVE
REREMOVED FROM THESE
COMMUNITIES?
HOW MUCH SAFER HAVE WE MADE
THESE COMMUNITIES?
THESE POLITICIANS NEED TO
TALK TO THE VICTIMS OF ALIEN
CRIME.
TALK TO THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
LOST CHILDREN AT THE HANDS
OF CRIMINAL ALIENS.
THEY NEED TO TALK TO
CALIFORNIA, THE CALIFORNIA
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION, THE
GOVERNOR'S SHERIFFS CAME OUT
IN SUPPORT OF ICE.
THEY DID A PRESS RELEASE
LAST NIGHT, IF I CAN READ
ONE SENTENCE IN THEIR PRESS
RELEASE IT SHOWS GOVERNOR
BROWN IS WRONG ON THIS
ISSUE.
THIS COMES FROM HIS OWN
SHERIFFS.
WE OPPOSE SB-54.
THE BILL WAS ENACTED, STILL
CONTAINING SIGNIFICANT
LIABILITIES WHICH INCLUDE
RESTRICTING OUR
COMMUNICATION WITH FEDERAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT ABOUT THE
RELEASE OF WANTED,
UNDOCUMENTED CRIMINALS FROM
OUR JAILS INCLUDING KNOWN
GANG MEMBERS AND OTHER
SERIOUS OFFENDERS.
HIS OWN SHERIFFS AGREE WITH
WHAT ICE AND DOJ IS SAYING.